Why Do Some Coins Have Ridges?
Putting ridges on some coins in America got
its start back in the 1700’s.
At this time, coins were actually made of
materials that were worth what the coin was
worth.
For example, a half dollar silver coin contained
fifty cents worth of silver.
Likewise, a $10 gold coin contained $10 worth
of gold.
As a consequence of this, people started to
shave off bits of these coins around the edges;
so now a $10 gold piece only contained, say,
$9.50 worth of gold.
The payoff came from that if they were very
careful when they shaved the coins, it was
very difficult to tell that anything had been
shaved off, so they could still generally
get their $10 worth out of the now $9.50 piece.
Over time, they’d collect the shavings and
when they had a large enough amount, go sell
them.
Eventually, the government decided to do something
about this and one of the methods to combat
this practice was to add ridges to these coins;
something known as “Reeding” the coins.
With the ridges on the edges, it became significantly
more difficult to shave anything off the coins
without detection.
They chose not to do so with smaller valued
coins that came out later, pennies and nickels,
because the metals these coins were made of
weren’t valuable enough for shaving them
to be worth the effort.
So that was then, why do they still do it
today when the coins are no longer made of
valuable metals?
Initially, supposedly it was because it was
easier and cheaper than modifying the existing
machinery.
Today however, it is to help the visually
impaired to more easily distinguish between
coins of a somewhat similar size like a penny
and a dime.
This is something unfortunately not done with
today’s American paper money, which is indistinguishable
to blind people without resorting to tricks
like folding them certain ways for different
bills, Braille money stampers, or much more
recently special apps which will identify
the bills for them.
Excepting via an app, the blind still need
someone to tell them what the bill is in the
first place when they receive it, so they
can do whatever they do to it to be able to
distinguish it later on their own.
Although, supposedly the government is working
on this problem with one of the most popular
suggested solutions being to adopt the new
Canadian system of imprinting the bills with
Braille.